President Trump used his first State of
the Union address to praise Americans
and the impact of his presidency this in
fact is our new American moment there
has never been a better time to start
living the American dream the president
touted the growing economy and
highlighted tax cuts and other changes
from his first year in office mr. Trump
also condemned criminals who are
immigrants deadly gang violence and the
opioid drug epidemic and he challenged
Congress to pass immigration reform
Democrats greeted much of the speech
with descent or stony silence a CBS News
poll shows three out of four Americans
who saw the speech approve of the
president's message
eight in ten Americans who watched say
they believe mr. Trump was trying to
unite the country rather than divide it
the audience according to our poll was
42% Republican and 25% Democrat major
Garrett is at the White House with
details of the hour and 20 minute speech
major good morning good morning
President Trump last night did something
he almost never does made the story of
his presidency about somebody else the
guest he featured and the stories he
told amplified what the administration
has accomplished and what it hopes to do
in the future
suggesting for the first time what's
ahead is less about him and more about
the country the state of our union is
strong because our people are strong
President Trump used his first State of
the Union address since taking office to
call for what has eluded past presidents
an end to bitter partisanship I call
upon all of us to set aside our
differences mr. Trump called for
compromise on immigration reform with
echoes of campaign rhetoric open borders
have allowed drugs and gangs to pour
into our most vulnerable communities we
recognize the parents of two teenagers
slain by ms-13 gang members 320 million
hearts are right now breaking for you
and called family based immigration a
dangerous loophole that should be
scrapped
single immigrant can bring in virtually
unlimited numbers of distant relatives
under our plan we focus on that true
hisses from the Democrats as there are
limits and long waiting periods the
president highlighted his first year
achievements including economic growth
and stock market gains but made no
mention of the Russia investigation that
has put him at odds with his own
government Americans love their country
and they deserve a government that shows
them the same love and loyalty in return
he suggested federal employees who
showed otherwise could be penalized so
tonight I call on Congress to empower
every cabinet secretary with the
authority to reward good workers and to
remove federal employees who undermine
the public trust or fail the American
people the president also tackled North
Korea citing two cases of Kim Jong Un's
human rights abuses including the
imprisonment and mistreatment of
American otto warmbier who died shortly
after returning to the u.s. Otto's
wonderful parents Fred and Cindy
warmbier are here with us tonight your
strength truly inspires us all the
president also singled out North Korean
defector ji sung-ho mamed as a boy and
later tortured by the regime I
understand you still keep those old
crutches as a reminder of how far you've
come
congressional Republicans know they will
run for re-election up against President
Trump slow personal approval ratings and
last night's speech was specifically
designed to give them space if they need
it to say they identify with the
Americans who represent the president's
policies and not necessarily himself
Norah well major thank you so much